-I want to talk about
the show, as well.
-Yes.
-Obviously one of the things
about the show
are the amazing judges.
You have a dream judge, though.
16 seasons in, who would you
be happiest to have judge?
-Well, I would've always loved
to have Michelle Obama,
because, I mean, I've been
asking for so many years...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...for her to come,
because, you know,
as a former First Lady,
I always thought that she was
so well-dressed, put together,
and everything.
And also, for young kids,
I thought it was fun
for her to come,
but she never came.
-Well, maybe -- maybe you're
using the same mail for her --
-No!
[ Laughter ]
I think you're getting it.
You just don't want to come.
-You have a line of intimates?
Am I saying that right?
-No, but I have to tell you,
this year what was so amazing
about "Project Runway," because
we had models of all sizes.
I don't know if you guys
all have been watching
"Project Runway,"
but it was really --
it was really amazing
because we have never done that,
and it's such
a big movement in fashion,
you know,
that we now see
not only the super-super-skinny
girls that we've been seeing
for so many years,
so now it's models of all sizes,
and it really was amazing.
-That's great.
-Yeah.
I'm so happy you're doing that.
You have, um...
You have a line of intimates.
-I do.
-And you are in the ad campaign
for the intimates.
That's you and your flowers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, because why not?
You know, people always say
"Maybe you're too old.
You shouldn't be doing this."
I'm like, "No."
We girls can always still do
what we want to do, right?
And still be sexy?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Why not?
Yeah.
So I wanted to be
with all these roses.
And, yeah, that's, like --
that's my new stuff.
-And last time you were here,
you brought me some intimates.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
My motto is always
"More boobs, less bra."
-Your motto
is "More boobs, less bra"?
-Yes, I like
to put them on the --
Because I do T-shirt bras,
I do super-comfortable bras
and all of that stuff.
But I like to always cut it back
as much as possible
and push everything in
from the right angle
so that they're really like
on perfect display.
-Yeah.
-More boobs, less bra.
I don't actually want to see
the bra in the end.
I just want perfect --
[ Whistles ] -- display.
-No, that's great.
Look, I'll be honest,
it wasn't my motto,
but you made
a really good case for it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-More boobs, less bra.
But don't you agree?
-What?
-Don't you agree you always want
to see more boobs, less bra?
-I -- Yeah.
Like I said, I never put
much thought into it, but, yeah.
Yeah, I've never been like,
"Oh, I wish there
was some more bra in here."
[ Laughter ]
-See?
I'm onto something.
Onto something, people.
-Speaking of all sizes,
this is really lovely.
You brought some intimates
last year, and I didn't --
I was wearing something else,
so I didn't want to put them on,
but our cue-card guy, Wally,
just the best he's ever looked.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Wally, thank you so much.
-What are you wearing today?
-Still wearing them.
What are you wearing today?
-I'm not wearing it today,
but I do have to wear them.
They're in my rotation.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
I came on the wrong day.
-Well, guess what -- looks like
you just hit a new career peak.
You're in Wally's rotation.
[ Laughter ]
Heidi Klum, everybody!